hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have been checking out x-files
season 10
technically it's season 10 but it's
really a miniseries it's six episodes
long I just I felt compelled to make a
video because it's so amazing it's a
really good example of a continuation of
an old series that's been off the air
for a while
done right on the flip side of that I
feel like heroes reborn is the same type
of series a continuation of a previous
series that just did not live up to
creative expectations because typically
the audience for things like this you
know when you bring back an old series
is initially just that core fanbase
depending on how big it is it might be a
little successful but they still have to
be compelling enough for everybody that
has never watched x-files to get hooked
and really enjoy it
now x-files is only in its second week
but they aired the first two episodes
back-to-back last week it crushed I
think just in the US alone it was like
20 million people watched it so yeah
it's doing really well and really it
doesn't even get good till episode 3 if
you're judging the series against itself
x-files episode vs. x-files episode
episode 1 of the new series is terrible
episode 2 gets a little bit closer to
the mark episode 3 is pure classic
x-files and one of the reasons why I
think episode 3 is the best so far is
because it's written by one of the
writers who wrote some of the best
episodes of the classic series so
there's just like a couple things that
x-files has in its favor that are
helping it be really really awesome when
it's only six episodes so there's the
idea that it's a little bit easier for
the writers to keep things from going
out of control they have the original
creative team back most of the people
that worked on the classic series all
the best creative people they're back as
well as the original stars so now I'm
going to start explaining what's going
on with the episodes so just spoiler
warning if you haven't seen through
episode three I'm gonna be talking about
what's going on starting with episode 1
so just like the classic series you have
the master conspiracy arc like this is
grand conspiracy of men then you have
the small arcs that represent each
individual x-file like they investigate
a case each episode those are the small
arcs self-contained each episode the
master conspiracy arc crosses over
across all six episodes so the big
master arc this season the idea is is
that there are no aliens trying to
invade the x-files them
or a tool meant to distract people of
authority like Mulder people in
positions of authority from the true
conspiracy of a cabal of men using alien
technology to take over the earth so
like the idea of the classic series is
that you have smoky man and his cabal of
people that are collaborating with
aliens to get earth ready for them to
take it over but at the beginning of the
new series they present it as being a
conspiracy within a conspiracy so the
conspiracy of the original series aliens
getting ready to invade is actually fake
aliens still exists but the way this
cabal of people got alien technology in
the first place is is that aliens saw
that earth was getting ready to tear
itself apart and they tried to come and
help the Roswell incident happened men
assassinated the alien took his ship and
then started developing all their
technology to take over the earth so now
for instance the idea is that when
people get abducted by aliens it's
actually them getting abducted by this
cabal of people using ships made based
on alien technology so that it looks
like they're getting abducted by aliens
people believe that conspiracy when
really it's just a bunch of men trying
to take over the earth so that's why you
here Mulder saying the x-files are bogus
they were meant to completely mislead us
at the beginning of episode 3 he's
talking about that see all these things
could be explained as fraternity pranks
stupid people doing stupid things but
then the brilliance of episode 3 is that
it shows him that some of those things
are probably real he witnesses the man
at the end turned into a lizard and then
skip off into the forest like it's no
big deal
so between episodes 1 & 3 he's done a
complete 360 degree turn around the
crazy track the look on his face at the
end of episode 3 is actually really
happy like he is happy to learn that
there are still things to believe in
it's not all bogus meaning just like
providing the opportunity that maybe
aliens really do exist and are part of
this conspiracy the whole brilliance of
episode 3 is summed up in that final
speech that guy gives at the end if you
want to re-watch that part of the
episode it just is so beautiful for
Mulder's like it's so absurd it's so
silly and guys like everything is absurd
everything is silly
moving into minor details that I know
all of you are wondering about Mulder
and Scully aren't together anymore and
they kind of explain why mulder got
really depressed when crazy Scully just
couldn't handle him
so they went their separate ways but
they still love each other she still
cares about him a lot and she's really
happy to be back on the team she even
says I'm just happy we're doing this
again and she's very genuine she's very
happy to be working with Mulder again
and it seems like being back in action
is rehabilitating Mulder they make it
seem like in the time that we haven't
seen Mulder and Scully Mulder has been
in a very dark place but you also get
the flashbacks to their child their son
so you learned that Scully had to give
him up for adoption to protect him
because of this giant alien conspiracy
and the way they weave it in it's really
hard to tell if she's imagining what
might have been or what happened and
that's one of the beautiful things about
the series is that you're always meant
to question the reality of the situation
with every turn and twist in the story
if you couldn't tell already episode 3
is definitely my favorite so far it
works amazingly well as an episode just
by itself even if you don't know what's
going on with this master conspiracy you
could show it to someone who has never
seen x-files before like if you have a
friend that's never seen x-files they
would totally be able to follow it and
it would be a lot of fun it's a great
horror mystery has a lot of heart and
it's just a lot of fun and those are the
things that all the best episodes of the
x-files had so when I say episode 3 is
true classic x-files that's what I mean
a lot of you have been asking me about
x-files videos I'm not planning on doing
a video for every single episode like I
said there's only six so I might do my
next x-files video after episode 6 and
just do like a review of the whole
series but it's a lot of fun you should
definitely check it out it's definitely
my favorite Monday show right now but
let me know what you guys think of it so
far and what's your favorite moment
since its comeback as you guys might
have guessed from my computer monitor
Scully
like the fake sex scene like they turned
into this weird porno story that was
completely false
funniest best moment ever so while you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for the Captain America
Civil War video that I just posted and
you can click here for all my Batman V
Superman videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five and
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you